[Musik]
was wenn du wirst ist der name einer
internet video kampagne an der oder ali
und ihr team arbeiten aufklärung über
die desaströsen folgen der weiblichen
genitalverstümmelung das hat sich oder
alice hilfsorganisation bei ventures auf
die fahnen geschrieben
eine frau die es überlebt hat spricht in
dem video erreicht sie nur eine person
kann es das schicksal einer ganzen
familie ändern
wir hören eine 18 jährige die nicht
verstümmelt wurde weil eine hebamme
ihrer mutter erklärte welchen schaden
das anrichten kann dass es gegen das
gesetz ist das sind sehr starke
botschaften dieses video geht mir sehr
nahe
das gespräch ist ihre waffe egal ob mit
eltern in workshops oder kindern in
schulen behutsam ohne tabus es dauert so
die 43 jährige ali bevor man über die
sache sprechen kann
doch aufklärung sei der schlüssel im
kampf gegen eine menschenverachtende
praxis kindesmisshandlung die
überzeugungskraft schöpft sie aus ihrer
eigenen geschichte mit sieben wurden ihr
in somalia schamlippen und klitoris
entfernt der beginn eines lebens mit
seelischen und körperlichen schmerzen
unzählige operationen in drei ländern
sind nötig bis oder ali mit 17 ihre
erste periode bekommen kann
bis heute leidet sie an entzündungen
kann keine eigenen kinder haben
ich glaube alles passiert aus einem
grund ich kann nicht ändern was mir vor
langer zeit angetan wurde was meiner
mutter meiner grossmutter urgrossmutter
und allen frauen in meiner familie
angetan wurde
aber ich kann die zukunft verändern kann
mich verändern ich kann über mich
bestimmen bestimmen über mein leben
wohin meine reise geht
als bürgerkriegsflüchtling landet ali
nach einer odyssee in london mit
krankenschwester aus ihrer arbeit mit
betroffenen in einer klinik entwickelt
sie den gedanken diese praxis muss
aufhören wird zur aktivistin 2015
organisiert sie die erste plakat aktion
gegen genitalverstümmelung im land und
6000 fälle zählt da die offizielle
statistik in großbritannien die
fallzahlen haben sich seitdem hat
genitalverstümmelung gibt es viele ort
mein motto erst von seiner eigenen
haustür beförderung in die welt sie ist
es passiert in familien von einwanderern
die jahrhundertealte tradition
mitbringen die nicht mit religion zu
rechtfertigen sei erklärt ali in rund 30
ländern noch immer praktiziert trifft es
weltweit jährlich bis zu drei millionen
mädchen
sie werden zufrieden sein erklärte dalli
wenn kein kind in großbritannien das
mehr erleiden muss ruhe finden wenn es
nirgends auf der welt mehr passiert ich
wache jeden morgen auf voller hoffnung
hoffe in dem ich ein weiteres kind
aufklären dass es weiß wie schlimm das
ist
ich kann mit eltern sprechen oder
anderen erwachsenen die verhindern
können dass es weiter passiert die dinge
werden sich enders ich weiß da dies in
den familien die ich kenne in meiner
eigenen ich habe zehn nicht und keine
einzige ist verstümmelt worden
ein leeres verweist das büro weil sie
und ihre arbeit nicht mehr gebraucht
werden
der traum von kodály dass es alle wissen
nichts rechtfertigt die verstümmelung
eines jungen mädchens nichts
[Musik]
das verfassungsgericht in warschau
erklärt am 22 oktober 2020 eine
abtreibung im falle von fehlbildungen
des fötus durchzuführen sei
verfassungswidrig
genau an diesem tag hat katar china von
schweren fehlbildung ihres babys
erfahren
ich habe nächtelang nicht geschlafen
geweint und überlegt was ich machen soll
eine situation eine entscheidung die für
frauen schon immer schwierig war und das
auch immer bleiben wird soll ich mein
kind abtreiben
geht es nach dem neuen urteil müssen
frauen diese entscheidung zukünftig
nicht mehr treffen denn es verbietet
abtreibung fast komplett zwar waren
abtreibungen schon lange nur noch in
ausnahmefällen gestattet doch jetzt gilt
legal möglich sind sie nur im falle
einer vergewaltigung oder
gesundheitliche gefahr für die mutter
diese fälle machten aber bisher nur
einen bruchteil der abtreibung in polen
aus wir leben in einer hülle für frauen
und das seit vielen jahren eigentlich ab
dem moment als das anti
abtreibungsgesetz 1993 eingeführt wurde
und jetzt ist diese hölle riesig und wir
wollen nicht mehr darin leben
zehntausende frauen ging nach
bekanntwerden des urteils auf die straße
demonstrierten bewirkt hat es nichts
seit ende januar ist das urteil
rechtskräftig
auch gynäkologinnen sehen die vorgänge
kritisch fühlen sich in ihrer
berufsausübung eingeschränkt und geraten
in einen ethischen gewissenskonflikt
wenn ich einer patientin in der zwölften
woche erzähle dass sie ein kind mit
einem tödlichen oder einem anderen
irreparablen schaden bekommt wird sie
für monate zur folter verurteilt
vor genau dieser situation und dem
möglichen leid des kindes nach der
geburt hat sich auch katharina
gefürchtet
ich habe gespürt ich werde es nicht
schaffen mein kind leiden zu sehen wenn
ich ihm nicht helfen kann
die beerdigung des kindes wäre außerdem
eine situation die ich nicht ertragen
katharinas entscheidung war gefallen
sie suchte sich hilfe bei einer
nichtregierungsorganisation und konnte
noch in polen ab treiben bevor das
urteil in kraft getreten ist
jetzt bleibt vielen polnischen frauen in
dieser situation nur noch der weg ins
ausland
[Musik]
sie nennen sich nicolas die kleverinnen
vorbereitung zu einer nicht ganz legalen
aktion in aller öffentlichkeit polin
markowitz und ihre mitstreiterinnen sind
unterwegs in sachen gewalt gegen frauen
ihre waffe botschaften an hauswänden
jeden zweiten tag wird in frankreich
eine frau opfer von gewalt wir wollen
das öffentlich machen
die menschen sollen die realität können
die angriffe die wir erleben und die
gezielte frauenfeindliche gewalt die
aktion heute gilt einem speziellen opfer
sara lee mich verstümmelt getötet von
einem mann der von der justiz entlastet
wurde steht an der wand
die rentnerin war vor vier jahren
grausam ermordet worden das hatte ganz
frankreich aufgefüllt der täter wurde
für unzurechnungsfähig befunden
wir sind mit der entscheidung nicht
einverstanden
der mörder hatte cannabis geraucht und
wurde trotzdem nicht verurteilt etwa
3000 kurse sind seit anderthalb jahren
in paris unterwegs rütteln auf mit
botschaften wie frauen sind keine beute
oder du bist nicht allein
anita weiß aus eigener erfahrung was
frauen angetan werden kann
mir wurde nachgestellt ich wurde auf der
straße geschlagen mit vergewaltigung
gedroht wir machen das auch für uns
verarbeiten so unsere eigenen erlebnisse
eigentlich ist es verboten wände und
zäune zu bekleben
doch die behörden drücken oft ein auge
zu die aufmerksamkeit ist den koloss
allemal sicher manche regen sich auf
andere haben nichts dagegen
es ist schon militant aber auch
künstlerisch auf jeden fall macht es
alle betroffen
poulin fotografiert alle botschaften und
stellt sie dann ins netz
über die sozialen netzwerke verbreiten
sich die inhalte sie nehmen größeren
raum ein
mit großbuchstaben gegen gewalt an
frauen durch ihre aktionen wollen die
kleverinnen den franzosen eine andere
perspektive bieten
[Musik]
wenn valeria costanza für ihre familie
einkaufen geht achtet sie mittlerweile
auf jeden cent sie kann schlichtweg
nicht mehr so viel ausgeben wie noch vor
einem jahr
ich muss die türken sollen weglassen
vorher habe ich zum beispiel lachs
gekauft um avocado lucky witch zu machen
jetzt nein in palermo arbeitete die 41
jährige seit jahren freiberuflich als
teammanagerin begleitete touristen
kümmerte sich um die logistik jetzt ist
der tourismus bei null und sie
arbeitslos ich hatte immer die koffer
offen schnell sachen austauschen und weg
dass es jetzt von einem extrem zum
anderen von dauernder bewegung in zum
kompletten stillstand
in italien gilt in der korona krise ein
kündigungsverbot für festangestellte
sowie valeria freiberuflich oder mit
befristetem vertrag gilt das nicht
der italienische arbeitsmarkt für frauen
ohnehin in schieflage und das problem
hat sich nun verschärft 70 prozent der
frauen in italien arbeiten in genau den
sektoren die besonders stark vom block
dann wegen corona betroffen sind der
kauf hotels und gastronomie tourismus
und haushalt diese sektoren sind zudem
die in denen man typischerweise verträge
ohne folgen auflösen kann
italiens regierung weiß dass sie frauen
in arbeit bringen muss wenn die
wirtschaft dauerhaft wachsen soll
doch über zwei drittel derer die
momentan ihren job verlieren sind frauen
hierbei der hilfsorganisation salva mehr
in rom
spüren sie auch die folgen die zahl der
familien die von ihnen mit
lebensmittelspenden versorgt werden hat
sich seit einem jahr vervierfacht in dem
moment wo die arbeit der mutter wegfällt
oder auch die des vaters
das stürzt wahnsinnig viele familien die
sich in diesem grenzbereich zwischen
armut und normalität bewegen in den
abgrund
italiens regierung hat angekündigt die
jobsituation für frauen verbessern zu
wollen jetzt in der korona krise hat
sich besonders offenbart wie notwendig
das ist
[Musik]
gleichberechtigung in medizinischen
studien fehlanzeige
denn meistens wird vor allem an und für
männer geforscht kardiologin kathrin
gebhart fehlt das nicht hinnehmen denn
es hat zur folge dass leitlinien die wir
im klinischen alltag anwenden oder auch
normalwerte überwiegend für männer
gelten und mir aber keine solchen
leitlinien für frauen haben
denn bei vielen erkrankungen zeigen
frauen andere symptome als männer
zb beim herzinfarkt und das hätte martha
schroff das leben kosten können denn sie
wurde von einem herzinfarkt überrascht
ich habe mich ins auto gesetzt bin
losgefahren und merke wie mir schlecht
wird
ich habe es kaum nach hause geschafft
hatte magenschmerzen
erst am nächsten morgen wählt sie den
notruf zwölf stunden zu spät
martha stock überlebt weiß aber nicht ob
ihr herz ich je wieder ganz erholen wird
viel zu oft erkennen frauen einen
herzinfarkt nicht rechtzeitig denn
worauf man lernt zu achten sind eher
männer symptome am universitätsspital
zürich erforscht kardiologin katrin
göppert geschlechterunterschiede beim
herzinfarkt
männer kommen oft mit brustschmerzen und
und die dann ausstrahlen in den linken
arm das ist so das an was man denkt wenn
man an einem herzinfarkt
bei frauen äußert sich der herzinfarkt
oft anders mit bauchschmerzen rücken
schmerzen übelkeit erbrechen dass viele
studien in der medizin hauptsächlich
männer im fokus haben ist ein echtes
problem
der frauenanteil bei studien zum herzen
do 18 bis 24 prozent
und so vielen daten auch darüber wie der
weibliche körper auf medikamente und
andere therapien reagiert eine
konsequenz von diesem
mangel an daten und von diesen
klinischen studien ist das eben frauen
viel öfters nebenwirkungen haben als
männer
1,5 bis 2 mal so viel das will kathrin
gebhard ändern denn gerade mit dem alter
werden die unterschiede beim herzen noch
größer frauenherzen schrumpfen und
müssen dafür stärker schlagen
männerherzen nicht in einer studie
erforscht kathrin gebhard warum stress
bei frauen eher zu herz
durchblutungsstörungen führt als bei
männern
und das ganze kann eben frauen insgesamt
verwundbarer machen zum beispiel einen
herzinfarkt auftritt bei frauen ist es
eben so dass die oft emotionaler stress
psychischer stress psycho sozialer
stress in der familie einen herzinfarkt
auslösen kann
bei männern ist in der überwiegenden
anzahl doch physischer stress also
anstrengungen bewegung was ein
herzinfarkt auslöst kathrin gebhard
möchte bessere prävention und
behandlungsmethoden für frauen
entwickeln damit patientinnen wie martha
schroff besser geholfen werden kann